so you mentioned Abraham
prophets uh Prophet Muhammad is deeply
venerated in Islam obviously but other
prophets are as well Jesus being one of
them um what are the similarities and
differences in the teachings from
these two
prophets well Islam refers to this idea
of submission to one God and attaining
peace in the process and refers to the
way of
life that prophets have all come with
which is this idea
of
monotheism and serving that one God in
the way that he commands you to serve
him uh so to us uh as it says in the
Quran that we do not distinguish between
the prophets all the prophets came with
one message One mission uh there's a
coherence in the Creed there's a beauty
in the foundation of what would become
the legislation of each of those
prophets and we see them all as siblings
in prophethood and so we say Abraham
peace be upon him we say Jesus peace be
upon him we say Moses peace be upon him
we say Muhammad peace be upon him we
believe that Moses came to confirm what
came from Abraham Jesus came to confirm
what came from Moses Muhammad came to
confirm what came from Jesus they upheld
the same message God did not change over
time uh nor did the centrality of his
message of monotheism change over time
and so uh to us it's one beautiful house
uh there's a saying from the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him where he
describes the house of prophethood each
Prophet being a brick and him simply
being the last brick of a beautiful
house and so we love the prophets of God
and we believe that they each came with
the legislation that was necessary for
the time but with the same
message so the messages fundamentally
the same is there difference in emphasis
for example the emphasis on Love With
Jesus yeah you know this is it's like
when you talk about MLK and Malcolm to
an extent ex except there was actually
some difference right between MLK and
Malcolm uh you know I just think that
the difference is exaggerated between
them but um I I don't think that Moses
didn't emphasize love but Jesus
emphasized love and then Muhammad didn't
emphasize love peace be upon them all I
think that they each
emphasized um the the same attributes
and and names of God and and ways of
knowing god uh but there were of course
changes within legislation changes
within uh the Divine Law but the Divine
Spirit uh remained the same and so I
don't I don't see them as being counter
uh to each other uh nor do I see that
any Prophet um betrayed the message that
came before them I think they're all
part of the same beautiful
message that we have to be at Harmony
with our creator and that we turn
towards him for our guidance and that
when we do so uh we establish uh a
greater uh a greater existence here on
Earth and so I think that that's
something that's consistent throughout
the message of all the
prophets
that